coming up on 5 25 on your wednesday
morning two types of speeders are
bothering a northwest valley viewer
gail writes first about the exit ramp
tailgater getting off the 215 beltway at
cheyenne people practically ride up your
bumper going at least 70 on a 45 mile an
hour exit scares me every time then
there's the wild wild west speeder on
lake mead from thomas ryan a 35 mile an
hour zone not i was going 40 people
passing me at least 70 plus with no cops
around it's like a free-for-all no
wonder there's so many crashes
well gail we are passing your comments
onto metro and nevada state police
highway patrol now law enforcement
standard answer is that unless they're
on a saturation patrol an officer is
probably only going to go after a
serious beater if they come upon them
and are not on their way to a higher
priority call buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone and you can
join the drive and you crazy
conversation at traffic eight and eight
news now dot com